[Music]
yeah yeah
loneliness heart a voice I was totally
knocked out
oh you missed something if you don't see
her live
[Music]
there were times when I would look up
the garden I go why is it happening to
me
I come from a family of seniors my mom
she was a little tough on Whitney
because she knew her Whitney asked they
were always a lot secrets
you know resulting that you don't deal
with these tell me that Robyn Crawford
Robyn was her safety net Bobby was
jealous
his heart was he wanted to be able to
stage he wanted to be in the forefront
and eventually she stepped down to lift
him up
you guys saw her anywhere else now one
thing Paul that jewel ain't [ __ ] yet
girls singing off-key why did he insist
he do more what was Whitney's drug of
choice what was it that drove them apart
how much do you think you spend did John
ever try and get rid of Robert were they
in love
you must have known about the drug use I
never knew there was any addiction do
you think she understood herself all the
men hearing their sing the star-spangled
banner she made people proud that they
were Americans
[Music]
she was beautiful I'm singing music from
my heart hot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]